l presidente yo bailé estuvo hoy en
todos los lugares donde los cuatro
aviones secuestrados por 19 terroristas
estrellaron empezó los actos
conmemorativos en nueva york que después
fue a shanksville pensilvania y por la
tarde fue al pentágono guardó silencio
pero su general mark miller y comandante
en jefe de las fuerzas armadas de eeuu
insistió que la lucha por los valores y
la democracia estadounidense de los que
perdieron la vida no fue en vano el ex
presidente george bush por su parte
también habló y dijo que lideró un país
unido después de los atentados
terroristas una unión que ahora aparece
distante por su parte el ex presidente
donald trump fue el único de los ex
mandatarios vivos que no estuvo presente
en ninguno de los actos de homenaje a
las víctimas del 11 de septiembre trump
se limitó a emitir un comunicado en el
que criticó la estrategia de joe biden
en afganistán en vez de recordar a las
víctimas y saludar entre otras cosas el
papel de los policías los bomberos y los
rescatistas